[Musique]
alors esprit cette grande nouvelle que
nous allons déplacer la tour eiffel oui
nous allons faire de dimanche tranchait
environ d'une quinzaine de mètres de
profondeur ensuite nous allons mettre de
très grosses grosses rails et ensuite
nous allons mettre les pieds englober de
ciment de béton armé ensuite nous
mettons donc pour quelles raisons
techniques pour déplacer la tour eiffel
ah bon mais parce que c'est très
difficile j'imagine de la traîner comme
ça bien sûr on ne peut pas déplacer une
tour eiffel de ce poids là comme ça on
nous sommes forcés de prendre mettre de
gros troll par exemple à l'école
militaire nous allons mettre des treuils
très puissant et nous allons la tirer
progressivement un mètre à leur mettons
quand maximum et ensuite
nous allons la mettre environ à 100 150
mètres de l'école militaire et
pouvez-vous nous dire pour quelles
raisons vatan déplacer la tour eiffel
haye compte faire un stade municipal
d'environ cent mille personnes juste un
autre emplacement si je comprends bien
mais pourquoi n'at-on pas annoncé cette
nouvelle bien avant bon c'est un peu
secret quoi assez délicat gym à jouer il
ne savait pas exactement ce qu'ils
voulaient faire si vous voulez la
démonter ou pour la reconstruire là bas
ou alors là la tirer alors maintenant
nous le prenons procédé américain nous
allons là le déplacement c'est comme on
déplace en amérique exactement légumes a
d'ailleurs on le fait en france on
déplace une maison à l'emplacement vu
lui et les travaux monture et combien de
temps faut compter deux ans deux ans de
travaux et combien de personnes vont
participer à l'opération aube à une
fouille tout sera en place raconté
environ 3 400 personnes
alors ici oui mais vous avez la tour
eiffel qui fait à l'heure actuelle 300 m
ça paraît pas mais c'est quand même du
joli travail mais dans deux ans si on
venait à paris vous ne reverrez plus on
a repéré plus non plus à cet
empressement ce qu'elle sait elle sera
enfin c'est l'école militaire
ray percevait la voix tout en tout temps
font là-bas
à déprécier la tour eiffel
ah non non non la démonte absolument pas
ça sera montée sur chariot et vérins et
tirez pas
d'école non non ça gênera pas oui
l'école militaire passera en dessous les
oui oui s'est passé ça s'est quant à lui
dit favorable à l'or un pied à pied par
pied on va la mauvaise on verra
que pensez vous du fait qu'on va
déplacer la tour eiffel est embêtant
pour vol dix ans que je suis ici alors
comment je vais faire je vais van de
poele vous savez qu'on va la placer
juste en face de l'école militaire avant
je pourrais pas y aller devant l'école
militaire pour quelle raison ça regarde
la place de paris y'a pardon quoi ça
regarde la place de paris lé commandant
de la place de paris ces militaires
devant l'école et vous pouvez pas
rentrer de marrons la surnombre à vous
ici ça fait partie de la préfecture de
police mais l'avant ça fait partie de
l'armée et alors qu'en pensez-vous en
définitive qu'allez vous faire vous bah
je sais pas j'ai pas je pense qu'on va
offrir
le
renverser
j'avais vente de marrons frères hamia se
démerder serrurerie
[Musique]